this is a a a monument in Montreal it's
in Montreal that's why I care about it
so much you know the Museum of Fine Arts
bought a church across from itself and
uh used it to show art and so the
beautiful old church you know and then
they commissioned a monument to put in
front of the church and this is the
monument right the transformation is is
full right the broken empty Angel whose
wings are falling off that has an empty
chest uh that has no face you know that
is half mechanical half flesh you don't
know what it is and these types of
statements are not they're not arbitrary
right it's like if I take your picture
of your mother and I rip it
like you know what that means
you know if I if I show a disfigured
version of someone you love you know
what that means
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
Jonathan pajoto is a professional artist
writer and public speaker who comes to
us from Quebec Canada
he lectures in universities conferences
and numerous venues on Art and the
symbolic structures that underlie our
experience of the world
if you're like me you first encounter
Jonathan through one of his many
engaging YouTube conversations on the
symbolic world
and if you're not already one of his 177
000 YouTube followers
I encourage you to sign up
that number
indicates that the topics we're talking
about here today have a broad resonance
as we heard earlier in this morning not
only with people of Faith but people
asking questions about meaning and
purpose and how to integrate art and
Beauty into identity he's a skilled icon
Carver
and as you heard from Aiden earlier this
morning he's also an artistic
entrepreneur because he started the
Orthodox Arts Journal that's trying to
revive liturgical art today he gives
carving workshops with a hexamerin
school of ecclesial Arts
uh which is accredited through pontifex
University he's also working on a
graphic novel and I heard last night
maybe on some fairy tales so he is an
artistic creative entrepreneur we are
delighted to have him following his
presentation there will be a
conversation between Jonathan and myself
as well as RJ Snell who also hails from
Canada
and he is here locally now at the
Witherspoon Institute where he's the
editor-in-chief of public discourse he
studied philosophy and taught Philosophy
for for quite a number of years at
Eastern University and the Templeton
Honors College he is widely published on
natural law ethics the liberal arts and
a giant now in the Catholic intellectual
tradition so after we hear from Jonathan
we will then have a conversation with
myself RJ and Jonathan thank you
Jonathan
thank you
so first off um
I'd like to thank margarita
and David and Aiden
um this is a
a bit of a tangent but it's important to
understand that I started wanting to
thinking that maybe I could carve icons
I could do liturgical art professionally
almost as a as a dream as a prayer as a
hope you know maybe about
20 years ago but about 10 years ago the
situation in my life made it possible
that possibly I could maybe do this
maybe at first in my spare time wasn't
sure trying to figure out how to to make
it happen and uh and David Clayton who's
right here is the very first person to
ever uh write about me you know kind of
promote my work just just talk about
what I was doing and and the same with
Aiden you know Aiden
for those who are not in the Orthodox
world or not in the world of liturgical
art there are waves of artists and in
some ways the waves that came before are
the ones who struggled the most and who
made it easier for those that came after
and Aiden is part of that wave that made
it possible for so many of us who are
able to paint icons to to to make that
it's credible that we could create
liturgical art and uh he was also one of
the first people that I wrote when I was
kind of struggling and and he was an
icon Carver he he was actually doing it
and I wrote him sent him some images of
my carvings and his criticism of my work
was extremely helpful uh and and just a
kind of common sense about how to go
about this was very helpful to me so
it's a great pleasure to be able to to
speak with you and to meet all of you
for the first time in person so I want
to thank you for that
um it's one of the it's one of the Prime
reason why it came was like oh I get to
meet Aiden and David all right I'm there
I'm coming
um
and so what I what I want to talk to you
about today is I want us to maybe start
thinking a little differently about art
or kind of provoke you to think
differently about art uh I'm very
fortunate that Aiden went before me
because he really set the stage uh for
for for what I'm gonna say I almost
wanted to like it when you hear someone
speak and and he really does a good job
you almost want to kind of reformulate
everything just before starting but
we're kind of we're gonna go along and
I'm going to try to I'm going to try to
to answer also some of the the the
powerful ways that Aiden presented this
uh His Image his vision of liturgical
art and so in the modern world we we
have a
you know we we are the fruits of the
avant-garde right we are the fruits of
Modern Art and there's a lot of tangents
in modern art but one of the things that
modern art has done and and not just
Modern Art but even the romantics before
you know even the pre-moderns there's a
sense in which we started to understand
art in a few particular ways one was to
understand art as something like
questioning right what the artist
questions the artist pokes the artist
provokes and tries to change and tries
to to revolutionize the means of of of
of of seeing the the cultural means and
so we are left with this idea you know
the creative artists who who is trying
to find some new way of representing
things to challenge the old ways of
seeing and this is a very deep uh this
is a very deep kind of underlying
assumption that we have in the manner in
which we understand art and so you know
of course the king of this is who who
really went so far you know as to to
just take common objects put them in the
gallery you know to to play with
identity you know to to to to question
identity itself in his art production
and and this is like the culmination of
what it is and people like Matt said
Deshawn became in some ways the the
Pioneers for what then became
Contemporary Art whether it whether it's
uh pop art you know Andy Warhol and all
the way up to today the contemporary
artists are in the line of of
um
and so
you all know Banksy now here's a here's
a very powerful theatric example of of
what it is that we tend to think that
art is and so Banksy had this very
theatrical stage I'm sorry it's
obviously staged but you know he they
brought one of his paintings out to sell
at auction and while they were doing the
auction it started to shred into pieces
you know as they were selling it and
everybody just celebrated this thing and
now the piece is worth way more than it
was when when it was just a painting you
know but this type of of gesture uh is
is a is a you know it's a it's a prime
example it's a very recent example of
how it is that we understand what it is
that we understand are to be you know as
this idea of questioning that's
provoking you know the punk rock rock
and roll idea of what culture is
um
and so when I want to bring you towards
is a a different perception of Art and
it is in some ways the more Universal
perception of art now I don't think
there isn't room for the provoking there
isn't room for the the fool the holy
fool who who you know make sure you know
that the king is in God right the
graffiti artist that reminds you that
this this thing doesn't isn't full in
itself there's a role for that uh but
because we're so unused to thinking
about art in the very ancient more
traditional way we almost have to re
to relearn how that is and so you know
the word art means well fitted together
right that that's what the the word
means it's actually close to the word
also in Greek Techni which is our origin
of Technology uh and even Oasis which is
the origin of our idea of poetry comes
the root of it is something like making
right so this idea of bringing things
and putting them together properly
towards their purpose right that is the
manner in which the Ancients understood
art and so you have a there's an idea
there's a pattern there's a episteme
there's a there's a high understanding
and now you want that to land in the
world and so in order to do that you
have to gather things together and you
know bring them together and make the
thing visible for us right and so this
is actually very much closer to the way
that the Ancients understood what art is
and and and funnily enough like so much
so much irony in the modern world in
America and in the west it took someone
who came from Ceylon so Ananda kumara
Swami who is up here being quoted was
the when a curator is at Boston museum
at the beginning of the 20th century and
he was the one who for the westerners
reminded them reminded them that ancient
art that the the that the medieval art
the liturgical art but also the art of
all cultures in is first and foremost in
light of this that is Art the art of
carpentry the art of cooking the art of
wine making the uh but also the art of
rhetoric the art of poetry you know and
then the art of painting the art of
sculpture that these are all ways in
which someone is skillfully capable of
gathering
means together towards a purpose right
towards the Telos towards something
which is the reason why the object
exists in the first place and so this is
really a you know it's it changes our
way of of thinking about art you know
because not only in the Contemporary
world we understand art as being
provocation as being questioning as
being uh you know kind of poking at the
system we also tend to understand art as
something which is
received as a viewer right received as a
as public and so you have a performer
and you have a public you know you have
a painting and you have a viewer and
this is so ingrained in ours right it's
the root of entertainment it's the it's
what brings us to watch our television
screens but there is a far deeper way of
understanding art in my my estimation
that is more about this Gathering
because the Gathering that the ancient
Arts did was not just the Gathering of
the stuff
but it's also the Gathering of the
people
and it's also the Gathering of the
people around that care for the thing
you're doing but if you make a good meal
and you do it well it's not obviously
it's not just about making a good meal
right it's about the people that will
come in and sit with you and enjoy it
with you and that's true for anything
right it's true for making a piece of
furniture right you don't just make a
piece of furniture because you dream it
up in the morning you make a piece of
furniture to hold clothing to sit on to
participate in the life of people and so
the this ancient vision of art is not
only Gathering the stuff but it also
ends up being Gathering people into the
purpose that that the art is making
manifest okay and so and there are a few
people in the 20th century that actually
started to have inklings of that
starting to to re-understand it for
example interestingly enough Heidegger
in his questions concerning technology
you know because for the Ancients there
was no different no difference between
art and technique these were the same
you know when it says in Scripture that
that Christ was the son of a carpenter
what it says is that Christ was the son
of a tecton
the son of a Artisan right the son of
someone who makes things and for the
agents that there was no difference
between I mean there's a difference
because obviously making a piece of
furniture and making a painting is not
the same skill but it was all about
bringing these things together and so so
Heidegger in Reading
uh the Ancients and reading Aristotle
particularly he comes to this image
where he says that Techni technology or
Arts right is a mode of unveiling right
it's a mode of revealing because whoever
builds a house or a ship or forges the
sacrificial chalice reveals what is to
be brought forth and so the artist
right gathers the things together so
that all this wood all these bits of
stuff become a boat become a chalice
become something which has Telos
something which has purpose okay uh
and so it's very important to understand
that and when we understand that then
when we look at Ancient Art we have a
different a different perception you
know one of the difficulties that we
have even looking at ancient art is of
course that we encounter these things in
museums that are septicized that are
reduced you come up to a statue that is
on a pedestal with a nice blank wall
behind it and then you just look at the
art now of course you know none of that
art was made that way none of that art
was made to be participated with that
way it's fine there's nothing wrong with
the museum it you know the especially
since these art these Arts don't have a
participative role to play anymore it's
it's wonderful to be able to see them
but the the agents in every culture
would have understood the Arts mostly
this way right in the sense that
this is the building that is the highest
point in our city
it's dedicated to the god that is the
patron of our city and we make these
things that bind us together as a city
so for Athens to exist the Parthenon is
key right it's it's this Gathering
Together of things is gathering together
of people this Gathering Together of
attention
right the reason why these temples were
often higher than all the other
buildings so that everywhere in Athens
you could look up and you could see the
thing which is binding you together you
could see this image of your Patron uh
god let's say that is binding you
together
um and so this is uh the the this will
make you now again see different things
so if you think for example of folk
dancing then all of a sudden folk
dancing takes on a very different
Allure
you know we think that dancing we think
that you know dancing is something you
go to a performance and you watch ballet
you sit there and then you watch the
ballet that is somehow High culture
right that is the highest form of
culture is to to to be a an observer of
people that are doing something with
Excellence now there's a very there's a
big difference between that and
something like folk dancing because what
does folk dancing do folk dancing makes
you participate right square dancing in
the United States for a long time did
something like that force you to
participate but not just to participate
right the traditional clothing the
traditional music the language of our
culture and so there's a way in which
folk dancing becomes a concentration of
a certain level of identity
that's a good way to understand it it's
like I have something in common with
these people and it's actually the
reason why I live with them it's a
reason why we're not just a bunch of
strangers you know like in this in the
suburbs but we actually live together
with reason and with a common identity
and so we have a way to celebrate that
we have a way to remember that
right we have a way to to to to bring
all this stuff together so now the dance
the costume the music all of that
becomes art
becomes art in the sense that I'm trying
to get you to understand it becomes this
joining together of things of people of
aspects of reality together so we can
recognize them as an unveiling of unity
right it's like oh yeah we're Bulgarian
or whatever like we we have something in
common we're we're a group
and and once you understand that then
you know this is this is the beauty of
what Aiden was bringing out this notion
of liturgy right this idea of liturgical
practice where in the church you have
all these things that were made with
love and attention by people and that
enter into a dance together
in order to manifest the very reason why
we're together in the church it's
different from this because we're not
just celebrating or participating in the
reason you know the fact of being this
or that group or this or that you know
uh having this or that origin in common
but we are celebrating the very source
of reality itself
we are celebrating the the reason why
everything exists right
right why all things exist is something
that we're celebrating when we come to
church and we are in the building and we
have all these these objects this music
you know the words all of this comes
together with the people in order to
reveal this and make us participate in
in that reality
and so
this can help you understand maybe also
why
because so these are some of my carvings
the understanding this and there are a
few people in this room that had the
same Revelation
understanding this and understanding the
power that art has to bind us towards
that which is most important
you know
is what made us move away from the
Contemporary Art world what made us
realize that there's a richness here
that people have forgotten there's a
richness here that is is really tapping
in to the way the world works
it's not just it's not just something
that was is a nice picture or that is a
nice object that I can look at and enjoy
but it's more than that right it is it
is a form of a deep form of
participation in the way that we exist
together and actually in the way that
reality
reveals itself to us
um
and so of course
there's still a lot of that today we
often don't think about it but there's
still a lot of this idea of art as
participation of art as celebration and
usually the remainders of that is of
course Civic art the public spaces or
the you know the go to Washington DC why
would you go to Washington DC it's not
like you can talk to the president or
anything you go there to liturgically
participate
in the common origin that binds you
together as a nation you know and so why
would you go and look at a statue of
this dead guy
uh you know and you know I'm gonna be
really I'm gonna push you but it's like
there's a little bit of veneration
there's a little bit of I want to stand
there and look at the image of someone
that I recognize as having uh that
participating in the reason why I'm here
like it I look at this image and I know
that one of the reasons why the United
States exists as a country that is one
is because of this person okay and so it
is liturgical you cannot you won't be
able to avoid liturgical the if you try
to break it down and you try to avoid
liturgical you're gonna end up in
Graceland and you'll be looking at
Elvis's shoes like you just cannot avoid
it right or you'll be dressing up as
Obi-Wan Kenobi with your lightsaber
right that you cannot avoid this this is
something that is deeply human and the
most cynical anti-religious person will
unironically dress up as Obi-Wan with
his lightsaber
and we'll go to Comic-Con and we'll just
be so excited to enter liturgically into
the story of Star Wars Okay so
I just want I just hope you can kind of
see how inevitable this is you know and
in this image you actually see that the
artist tried to portray this in the very
image itself you know in the seat that
Abraham is sitting on there are the the
fastest they are the this ancient Roman
symbol of binding Unity right all these
sticks that are bound together in order
to manifest unity and so the the artist
clearly understood that not only is this
person
one of the reasons why that Unity exists
but also
at a secondary level the people who come
there who read the the inscriptions and
the stone who look at this statue are
reenacting are participating to some
extent in that story and in that that
identity okay
um
now
this also means
that we have to be very attentive we
have to be very attentive when that
starts to
shatter when it starts to break you know
and and and I don't want you to to say
any statement of for or against whatever
but it's important to understand that
when those liturgical things
when they get taken down
there's a world that is changing
right there's a memory that is changing
there's an identity that is changing and
you can't avoid that you know the
Christians took down the Roman god
statues
and when they did that it meant
something very profound it meant the
world is no longer the same the thing
that binds us together
is no longer the same as what it was
before there's a deep transformation
which is a foot when you start to see
this happen and so it's important to pay
attention and to and to
it's not my job to deal with that but
it's important to understand what is
happening and so this this of course you
know and this Aiden oh I want to talk
about this one last time so one more
time this this is also important to
understand that art that is Civic
and that is celebration that is
participating in identity
necessarily has to have certain forms
right if you take an art that is there
to question to poke right to rip at the
identity of something and you put it up
in a public space and you put it up as a
Civic Monument
you are entering very dangerous a very
dangerous place and the difficulty we
have and I'm saying this because there's
a lot of that that happened in churches
in the past 50 years and it wasn't done
on purpose it was done with with people
who were looking at the Modern Art
around them and not totally sometimes
understanding visually what the art was
doing not completely Gathering into
themselves the the implications of
showing broken people of showing you
know things that are cut things that are
things that are shredded and then just
putting that up in public spaces in in
the church uh you know just wanting to
kind of be modern and not realizing that
that there there are
and these are very organic they're not
arbitrary right it's like if I take a
picture of your mother and I rip it
like you know what that means
you know if I if I show a disfigured
version of someone you love you know
what that means
and so the fact that we just kind of
forgot that and we've accepted these
weird things and so this is this is a a
a monument in Montreal it's in Montreal
that's why I care about it so much uh By
David atmed
you know the Museum of Fine Arts bought
a church across from itself and uh used
it to show art and so the beautiful old
church uh you know and then they
commissioned a monument to put in front
of the church and this is the monument
and so
right the transformation is is full
right the broken empty Angel whose wings
are falling off that has an empty chest
that has no face uh you know that is
half mechanical half made half flesh you
don't know what it is and these types of
statements are not they're not arbitrary
and so you know what you're seeing in
some ways is the is the the evisceration
of the church which was now transformed
into something else I wish they would
have done it differently they could have
or they could have done it differently
but that's the way that they decided to
go at it
um
possibly for reasons
all right and so this of course is
you know I showed you an image of the
the Parthenon to kind of tease you a bit
or to poke you myself I'm sorry uh you
know there's a way in which there's a
problem with this that there is a
problem with this this thing you know
the gods fight amongst each other
right the identities fight amongst each
other the all these cultures they also
lead to conflict and War and so how do
we deal with that problem right the the
questioning of identity the the poking
at the system is Not always completely
illegitimate
because
identity leads to conflict it just does
that is part of that's part of the
problem and what you see in in scripture
is you see the beginning of a of a
of a transformation of the problem
there's a there is a very deep
relationship between art and identity in
the negative sense
in the in the Bible
and one which God transforms into
something beautiful and positive and
glorious but it's important to
understand it because we have to be
cautious about the way we enter into
identity and especially as people start
to poke at identity we sometimes want to
just react and say it's like no you know
I am this or I have I have this identity
we have to be very careful and so in
scripture the develop the development of
the Arts follow one thing they follow
the murder of Abel and so Cain kills
Abel and then Cain is chased away from
God
on on his body is placed a mark which
excludes him from
the presence of God we could say
and then that Mark leads Cain and that
exclusion leads Cain to develop
civilization to develop
the first thing he does is he builds a
city the first city is built by Cain
himself and then his descendants are the
origin of Music the origin of Metallurgy
the origin of tent making and so you see
in the descendants of Cain this this
strange thing why why is it that it's in
the descendants of Cain that this
happens and there are corollaries to
this actually in in other in other
cultures you know uh hephestos for
example is a is a it's almost like a
it's almost like a cane figure right he
is thrown out of Olympus for some
impropriety and he lands in Hades and
that it's in Hades that now he develops
the skill to make the beautifully forged
objects the the weapons the things that
the gods prize in terms of in terms of
Techni and in terms of art right the
capacity to to make things
um and so
why
why is that it has to do with the with
the problem it just has to do with the
problem of inside and outside it has to
do with the problem of identity because
once Tech once civilization starts war
starts it's it's inevitable part of
building a wall around your city if you
build a wall around your city means
there's some people that are inside and
there's some people that are outside and
those people that are outside
you know they're looking inside maybe
they want what you've got and now you've
got to defend your walls against the
people outside and it creates it's an
acceleration of the Fall itself right
that's what happens when Adam and Eve
take the fruit for themselves and are
see themselves as naked they immediately
see the other as a threat right right
away what happens Adam blames Eve you
know Eve blames a serpent it's right
away me you you know you're the bad guy
it's not my fault there's just this
immediate opposition which happens and
this this opposition is just a just a
part of of civilization and it ends up
being a part of of technology and of
human making one which is difficult to
deal with now
what what happens in in the
in the Bible is that God takes that and
transforms it powerfully right he does
exactly Aiden had such a beautiful image
taking it from Saint Ephraim saying
right the fruit of the knowledge of Good
and Evil think about it this way the
fruit of opposition of opposition
between two things right if taken for
you yourself becomes
yeah it becomes that it becomes
it becomes opposition now the if you are
given the fruit then it becomes it can
become life itself in the sense that
it becomes the capacity to distinguish
the capacity to distinguish is not wrong
but it has to be let's say it has to
come from Heaven is the good is the best
way to understand it has to come from
above and what you see in the story of
the Tabernacle is exactly that God
reveals to Moses the pattern of the
Tabernacle the Tabernacle is the memory
of Eden
that is what it is the Tabernacle is
based on the image of the Garden of Eden
it is the idea of I mean the Candelabra
that's there
and you also have the Cherub that are
guarding the ark guarding the the the
the Tabernacle and so there's a direct
relationship between the participation
in the in this space and a return to
Paradise a Return to Eden
and it is
you could say it's something like memory
perfecting itself slowly memory being
because memory is two things right
memory is distance from something
right and memory is also direction
towards something right when I even the
word like we remember
it's like we we bring multiplicity back
into its Talos when we remember
and so when you remember God when you
remember the heart all these these
Expressions that we use in in Christian
thinking uh
that is that is what you're doing you
know you're going to see that obviously
all this will lead up you know to
communion ultimately as this perfect you
could say Perfect Memory uh but this is
already What's Happening Here in the in
the the Tabernacle and so if you read if
you read Exodus you'll see it's not just
the Tabernacle it's the Passover it's
all these things which are remember
remember
what happened remember your origin
remember where you come from remember
what binds you together why are you
Israel because I am the god of Abraham
Jacob uh Abraham Isaac and Jacob that is
why you are Israel you are bound both by
especially this Revelation it's powerful
because God is saying I am the god of
heaven I'm the source of everything I am
supreme but I'm also the god of your
fathers
one comes after the other in some you
know in an important way I am that I am
but I'm also the god of your fathers I
am the place where you recognize your
origin to be in Abraham
right so it's a so the the participation
in the ritual of the Tabernacle the
remembrance of Passover the remembrance
of these feasts was always to remember
where you come from remember where you
know where where you are and that
becomes a way to participate in it or to
participate in something which is kind
of beyond the beyond the
beyond the now now like or just the the
commonality of everyday life
and so
now this this this this question again
like
right this is the problem right this is
this is the problem that I'm talking
about is that
Techni
Unity identity
often leads to this
it leads to Babel you know and this is
of course the ultimate image of the city
gone wrong right the city that tries to
contain everything the city that tries
to take the fruit for itself that tries
to make a name for itself and not
receive the name from above not receive
the Revelation from above but make a
name we're going to make a name for
ourselves right we hear that in common
parlance but this is of course what
leads to Babel in the kind of the the at
the complete Distortion of art into this
pride is best way to understand it
um
all right I want to speed up here but
what I want to show you is that this
idea of of memory and of Celebration and
of remembering is one which even though
we have this kind of Modern Art there
it's always there it's always kind of
it's this underlying current you're
going to see it if you pay attention
you'll see it and so everybody you know
this is he's the famous artist Jackson
Pollock is a famous artist you know he
he it's process it's it's all about
process it's not about the thing it's
about it's about this expressivity it's
about a kind of ordered chaos it's about
this this explosion of color and of end
of an of art uh and he's the avant-garde
right he's the one who's pushing the
boundaries right who's at the edge but
while this was happening and even the
teacher of this person is is this person
Thomas hard Benton and in the United
States you have this whole current
called regionalism that a lot of people
don't know about for some reason that
was a desire to you know with the crumbs
that are left to celebrate something
about about out our lives to celebrate
the worker to celebrate you know the
stories the the difficulties that people
that people went through and so there
was this this desire and you can see
that this type of art this type of Art
and the other is a completely different
nature they're just not in the same
world they're talking about things very
differently not just visually in terms
of subject but also in terms of purpose
right in terms of purpose and so
regionalism is the type of art that you
will find in the 1930s in Civic art in
the United States because it had some it
had the right way of celebrating of
remembering the things that the
sacrifices of our of our forebearers and
and putting them there for us to be able
to to see them okay now
you know
this is I want to show you how difficult
it becomes is that uh you have some
similar situation happening in Europe
and in Russia and there it goes the
other way that it went with Pollock is
that you have this push in Russia this
push towards supremacism and
constructivism to kind of break the way
that ain't people used to see the world
to really push it to its Edge you see
you know the craziest example is of
course in in uh in futurism Italian
futurism uh bocioni is a was one of the
members of the futurist movement in
Italy where it's it was really explicit
like art is violence art is destruction
art is this this this push that we need
to break everything to be able to move
into the future you know but that that
that can't hold it's almost like you
pull the pendulum so far and then when
it snaps then it goes into this
which is also Modern Art right this is
modern art
that that's Modern Art there
and there was obviously a version of
this in in in Germany as well uh and so
how do we how do we deal with that
because that's a problem I hope you
agree that's a problem
and this is a problem right it's like
what the Stalin the you know Stalin the
hero so so how do we avoid participative
art that wants to remember that wants to
make us connect to our Origins connect
to our particip to our to our world uh
to our to our commonality without
propaganda how do we do it
right because the modern artists that
were breaking everything some of them
had the right intuition about the
problem of propaganda right and we have
to understand that this is not a new
question you know Plato knew that in the
Republic Plato knew already the problem
of art the problem of poetry the problem
of rhetoric the problem of artistically
putting together things because they can
be used to manipulate your your your
idea they can be they can be used to
make you care for things that maybe you
wouldn't care about right it can they
can be used to make you think something
is important that maybe you shouldn't
think is important right that's
ultimately for us that becomes
advertisement it's like advertisement is
all celebration advertisement is all
participation but that's not what we
want right we don't want something that
is so shallow and so and so manipulative
and so how do we do it how do we deal
with this and I think that
I think that Christians you know as they
came into place and as the language of
the art in the church started to
establish itself I think they found what
I think is the the best solution and
it's one which is not arbitrary to
Christianity but is rather at the very
source of this the particularities of
what Christianity is
as images started to appear in the
Christian church and started to take
shape it took several centuries it took
a while for this to kind of gel and to
crystallize you know by the by the 10th
Century by the 11th century you could
say that
there were there were two basic images
of Christ two Central images of Christ
and one is the one we could call the
pentocrator which is Christ here shown
with the book and this is
it's an eschatological image
it's a Christ as he will appear in glory
it's Christ as he will show himself to
us when all has been revealed and all
has been brought together in the
finality right it's not just about
future it's something that can Pierce in
now it's something that you can
experience now but there is a sentence
which is beyond the the it's beyond the
mere historical something which is
piercing through from the other side
piercing through from that final moment
and then the other image that becomes
Central you know especially there is a
sense in which one becomes more Central
in the East one becomes more Central in
the west but it's a little over
exaggerated but then you have the cross
and so you know we have to
every time you look at a crucifix like
don't forget how weird that is
like don't forget that
you know you have this thing above the
iconastasis or above the altar in front
of you that is the image of a dead
person
and and it's and it's crazy
but
it's an interesting just just I'm going
to be utilitarian it's an interesting
idea
it's like wait a minute
at the top
the thing that's the most celebrated
is actually the thing that gives itself
oh the thing at the top the thing that's
actually most celebrated is the thing
that empties itself huh okay well that's
different from the King
right that's different from Athena or
Zeus that goes around raping everybody
it's like it's quite different right
it's quite different you know there's a
there's a different Vision it's the same
for this idea of of Christ the
eschatological Christ it's like no no
don't think you've got it
right don't think you've mastered it
it's coming it's coming over the horizon
right call for it ask for it ask Christ
come Lord Jesus but don't think that
you've you got it right like that you're
the one and so these two powerful images
they they're they're like I said it's
not arbitrary it's something about the
very nature of the of the of the
Christian faith which makes these images
the central images and bring the the
possibility to celebrate to Remember To
Worship
you know
at least given the possibility of
alleviating the problems of Pride and
the problems of identity doesn't mean
the Christians were always able to do it
you know your history obviously not but
there's a difference between there's a
qualitative difference between that and
the you know the the then the Augustus
the Son of God who is all-powerful and
is literally a manifestation of a Divine
principle in the world and that can rule
over you you know with his with his fist
or some other Roman Emperor or some
other ancient Egyptian pharaoh that had
right of life or death over everybody in
their Kingdom there's a there's a
there's a big difference between the the
two
so what what that will give in terms of
culture what what type of images it will
provoke can be very interesting to think
about this way and so this is a this is
this is a type of image that you'll see
in many medieval churches Orthodox
churches and what it is it is the rich
powerful person this in this case a rich
Aristocrat in Constantinople sometimes
the emperor himself sometimes the king
himself prostrating himself before the
true Emperor the true king
and what is he doing
he's offering the church but the church
the building
that is he's offering the art he's
offering the Arts to Christ right that's
what's going on there
it's like I paid for this church I hired
a bunch of Architects a bunch of
Artisans to make this beautiful church
and I and I'm offering it to Christ and
so the Summit is again eschatological
this image of Christ is the Christ he's
sitting on his Golden Throne he has
returned he is the the Christ that fills
up the entire Cosmos it fills up the
entire world this is what the art is
being offered to and then then you'll
notice that
in in uh let's say several there are
different images that manifest that this
is an image called the hetemasia which
is this image of the prepared throne
and so it's an image of the throne which
is prepared for the final revelation of
Christ
and so you know it's it's a beautiful
image of this offering up right it's
like gather these elements together
there's the book there's the throne
there's this Throne of the emperor which
is prepared for this final moment you
know and so that is what we do Aiden
this morning you know beautifully talked
about the the Eucharist in a way that
like might scandalize some of you
because he he came right up to it and
I'm going to push you over the edge he
said he said Eucharist is art
the gifts are art we're made them we
made the bread we made the the wine and
then we offer it up to become the very
blood and Body of Christ you know it's
like that's a really powerful image you
know in in in some moments during the
Byzantine period it was the Emperor who
would come up to the door of the of the
iconostasis of the of the the temple on
and would bring the bread to be to to to
hand over to the priest or the bishop
who would take it and then consecrate it
it's like here's my kingdom here's all
these things gathered right here's all
these things that are our works our
efforts all this stuff that we do all
these activities that we do and we're
offering up to become the body of Christ
and so that's a a very powerful image
and then that again and then the
Eucharist obviously it has
many there's there's Beyond symbolism in
The Eucharist but one of the aspects is
that emptying as well that's there in
the Eucharist right the Eucharist is
both is both the eschatological Christ
and also the Christ that empties himself
and gives his body and his blood for to
to fill us up
um
and so
I'm going to speed up really fast and so
this is one of Aiden's uh Ascension and
so if you if you think if you start to
think that way then you're you're going
to start to notice that a lot of the
images especially in the Orthodox
tradition is the tradition that I know
have a very strange eschatological
element you know in them and so this
image of Ascension is obviously an image
of the Ascension I mean it's the moment
that Christ Rose but it also is
eschatological in its very form
right it's revealing to you the the
structure of the world right the Divine
logos is above in heaven you know and
he's either going up or coming down
you're not sure this could be like the
return of Christ in in a very strange
way uh and then down below is the the
the footstool of of the throne the
mother of God is there underneath him
and then you have the church which is
gathered and how do you know it's
eschatological because Saint Paul is
there
why is Saint Paul there this is not just
a snapshot this is trying to bring you
into that moment where the entire church
is gathered in the in in the the in the
pantry in the one who rules over all
things
um
and so and then you have some images
with which have aspects of kenosis and
of emptying and so an example again is
in the image of uh of the Nativity where
Christ is represented as a child who is
already in the Tomb who's already you
know contained in this you know it's
weird for people again that story of
Jesus is so weird it's just so bizarre
we're so used to it we stopped thinking
about it like why was Christ laying in
the food trough for animals
right why because he he's em he's going
to the bottom right he's going to do it
he's going to do it when he dies but
he's already doing it now he's going to
the very bottom of the world the very
place where animals eat right to the to
the foundation of all things and so you
have this canonic element as well
all right and so
and then all of this is of course
leading to the final image right and
this is the final image which restores
the story from the beginning
we have to understand the Heavenly
Jerusalem as the final restoration
even of you could say Cain not say Kane
is saved I don't know God knows that but
it's it's the restoration of the very
first moment of that sin that sin of
murder that led to civilization is being
transfigured is being filled you know in
the image of the Heavenly Jerusalem
which comes down and if you read it if
you read the text
it's very powerful right it says I did
not see a temple in the city because the
Lord of God Almighty and the lamb are
its Temple the city does not need the
Sun or the moon to shine on it for the
glory of God gives it light and the lamp
is its lamp
this is where it's related to to what I
I'm telling you about in terms of how do
we make our identities proper how do we
make our rejoicing our celebrations
proper it says the nation will walk by
its light and the kings of the earth
will bring their Splendor into it
so what do the kings do they offer their
glory to God they bring their Glory into
service of the Heavenly Jerusalem
on no day will its Gates ever be shut
for there will be no night there the
glory and honor of the Nations will be
brought into it and again a repetition
of that very theme which is all our
identities all these little identities
that we have if we live them properly we
live them in service we live them in in
giving them up towards the true king and
so there's nothing wrong with being
American or Canadian or or French or
whatever identity that you that you
participate it doesn't have you could
also be like part of a soccer team or a
football team or part of of something
that you recognize as being you
something that you participate in that
gives you a sense of meaning and a sense
of purpose all those things can can
really be filled if they are ultimately
you know directed towards the the
Heavenly Jerusalem towards the highest
good towards towards the the highest
image and in this image again
surprisingly enough you have these two
images represented quite powerfully in
this particular image which is you see
the Christ you see Christ in glory
Christ as the king Christ as the ruler
of all the one who fills the world with
his power and his judgment and then on
him is the Lamb which is the sacrifice
and those two together are what these
two images I talked about this
eschatological and cannotic image coming
together as being what the Christian
what Christianity proposes as a possible
solution to to Art to Identity uh to the
way we participate in the world so thank
you everybody
[Applause]
thank you Jonathan
um I have to say that was fantastic I
was cheering there as you got to the end
and I want to give the first question to
RJ but don't worry I decided all kind of
summarize a little bit of what I heard
from Jonathan to get us going when I'm
teaching a great text or have students
listen to a great guest lecture I often
try to pull out some key scenes and I
wanted to do that here I was doing that
myself as I was listening and we were
having a conversation yesterday about
thinking visually I often kind of teach
visually okay how would I organize what
Jonathan said and I wanted to highlight
some really key terms and the mic is not
on so good okay is the mic on now great
okay sorry
um especially for those of you on live
stream
um what I would like to do to start us
off is to pull out what I heard were
some really key themes from Jonathan and
if we don't get through them all today
we also I mean this morning we also have
the breakout sessions with him later but
what I thought the very first thing you
said really struck me and I have like
this schema that I have right on the one
hand there's identity as performance
or identity as participation
I also heard you say
we can think of art as tearing down
or gathering
we can think of how we interact with the
material world and art as something
that's a manipulation
or a celebration
art can have an impact on our common
Life by promoting division
or Union
we can think that what goes into art is
purely
arbitrary
or there's form
foreign
then we can think about our relationship
to the material world as one of
possessing
or offering
and then I thought you pulled it
together so beautifully because after
kind of laying out those tensions around
the place of Art and identity and
culture
you then offered
a vision you know Aiden this morning
kept talking about art as offering a
vision and you offered an incredible
beautiful vision of what art could be
because you brought in the Transcendent
you brought in God you started with the
cross
and you talked about worship and the
eschatological and the Eucharist and you
essentially let us to see that the
proposal of Christianity is that the
Heavenly Jerusalem
can be made known through form and
through worship and through ART and then
flow back out in a healing River to a
culture that has suffered a lot of
division and manipulation and tearing
down and in a way of forgetting of who
we are as human persons so that's what I
took away from your talk Jonathan does
that sound uh do would you own that
most of it I would say
no and I didn't miss anything I just I'm
saying just I would say I I would say
that uh
I would say that at least in our
situation I I don't like the Heavenly
Jerusalem is eschatological right so in
some ways it can't be completely known
by human forms now it can be you can be
it can bring you closer right and so you
can be brought into an inkling and into
a a an anticipation and into a a let's
say a smell of of what is the final uh
Revelation and in some ways it has to do
so you know I I didn't go as deep into
the notion of memory but that's the best
way to understand it it's like uh you
know we think we only remember things in
the past but actually no we also
remember the future uh and that's an
that's a moment when we're remembering
the future you know we're we're actually
remembering in the in the future and you
do it all the time by the way it's not
weird it's not like this weird magical
thing I'm saying you know every time you
build something you're remembering the
future because you haven't made your
thing yet and so you're you're looking
into the in the the future and you're
remembering towards that point and that
and the Heavenly Jerusalem is the
ultimate version of that right
thank you I'll just say there's a
there's a term
um already and not yet that's a kind of
anticipation
I turn it on I think thanks so much for
your talk Margarita thank you for the
invitation thanks to all of you for
being here I apologize for my eye patch
I'm not cosplaying pirate whatever my
seven-year-old thing recovering from eye
surgery
uh Margarita had asked me to think about
some of the questions of Art and
Jonathan's talk as they relate to the
political common good of how we might
think of the the work of the artist
contributing or failing to contribute in
some ways from your own talk to the
ability to have a shared common
political life
um so we see this I think in many ways
in your discussion of the Gathering
Together the folk dance brings a common
good of the dance the temple which is
raised high above the city gives a
source of unity and direction to the
people so that there's a kind of common
good but I'd like to explore a little
bit some of the challenges that I think
we face at the Contemporary moment and
wonder if Art's up to the task in some
ways of needing to do what what we need
it to do
so first if we think about some of the
challenges facing Us in the political
common good
I think it's not the case that everyone
goes to Washington DC and venerates at
the Jefferson and Lincoln memorials if
anything it may be quite the opposite
uh so some months ago when Margarita
mentioned that I may be part of this
panel I watched some of your videos and
this week I thought I'd better watch
some of them again I was watching very
serious videos about symbolic realism
but then because of the wickedness of
the powers of the algorithms on YouTube
there was on the side a conversation
about the inverted pentagram talk about
you so of course I had to watch about
the inverted pentagram
and in your conversation you mentioned
how the pentagram the right side up
pentagram has a source of unity at the
head and then you have the the top of
the triangle and then you have the four
differences brought into Unity the
inverted pentagram is quite the opposite
the inverted pentagram is trying to in
some sense bring Unity at the bottom out
of the many
e pluribus unum
from the many one but it doesn't work
and you make of in that talk a very
interesting suggestion which is you you
suggest that in our own cultural moment
not having a source of unity we're
trying instead to fragment by going to
the margins those who were the
previously the oppressed or the
marginalized the sub-altern their
experiences are privileged
and there's not a veneration for Unity
in fact a whole lot of our culture looks
like the angel in front of the church
at Montreal
prime minister Trudeau recently said
that the nation of Canada has no
identity at all it's a post-identity
nation it's the inverted pentagram
that's why I moved to the United States
where it is also e pluribus unum though
but but not working so that's when the
political reality seems very difficult
two The Power of the Arts to do this
many years ago the Welsh poet David
Jones wrote his epic poem The anathemata
it's his attempt to recreate
British identity through ART and it
fails miserably
no one understands any of the references
to the Earth Arthurian Legends and in
fact the introduction to the poem begins
with his notion of the break
which is that because there is no
cultural memory there can be no art
he says the poet is dead the poet can't
make reference to Wood and assume that
the citizen will think of the Cross or
the Tree of Life there'll be no
reference at all you can't refer to
water because there'll be nothing there
to refer to
even some of the images that you refer
to here I wonder about their their power
so you show us the reference of tubal
Kane
the image of tubal cane that you showed
us is from the Spanish Chapel in Santa
Maria novella
those of us in my own School call that
Fresco the Triumph of Saint Thomas
Aquinas
but tubal Kane is in the very bottom
right of the piece
there's a narrative Unity prior to the
works of Cain if you think of the piece
at the top we have the Holy Spirit
descending upon the upper room where the
disciples are gathered around our lady
and she's immediately above Thomas
Aquinas
who is the source of synthesis it's a
Dominican propaganda piece
across the wall is the Dominicans
dressed as dogs attacking and tearing
apart the Heretics
Thomas is above a varuese Arias and
Nestor
and all of that Theology and holy spirit
provides the back story for the Arts and
Sciences and tubal Kane is on the very
bottom and the very right
and The Ordering of the Arts and
Sciences is from the least important to
the most important
yeah it's always the point of view of
the people in the icon that will help
you understand which side he's on yeah
and then very briefly the Tabernacle
that you referred to uh Lord Rabbi
Jonathan sacks used to use the image of
the Tabernacle in a very interesting way
he would say the story of Creation in
Genesis 1 is very short the story of the
creation of the Tabernacle is very long
it goes on and on and his take was it's
very easy for God to make a home for us
and very difficult for us to make a home
for God
but that the story of the Tabernacle was
in some ways the story of the formation
of the Hebrews themselves as they made
it but then he would also remind the
reader but of course there had been a
story before of God making the people
so what is it that we're remembering now
if the break is so severe and are the
Arts really up to the task
um no I don't think I don't think the
Arts are up to the task in it it's if
you think of it in the political realm
there's no way there's no it's not
possible
um that you know there's a
you can really understand it if you want
to understand what's going on you can
understand the culture in what it
celebrates if you want to know where our
culture is just look at what it
celebrates and then you will see what's
going on in that culture
um and uh
right we could say in some ways that uh
if you think of a traditional Church of
like a medieval gothic church you had
the altar in the center and then you had
the knave and the narthex and then
outside you have the Gargoyles and the
and the weirdness and it's actually you
know we looked at the manuscripts
yesterday and and in late medieval
manuscripts they had that very structure
in the manuscript itself where in the
middle of the manuscript you had even a
sacred image and then on the outside and
on the margins you had even sometimes
quite lewd and and you know vulgar or or
humorous or kind of crazy images of
mixtures of different animals and all
this stuff and so uh you know there's a
sense in which
our whole culture right now is like
worshiping the carnival is the best way
to understand it it's like like we're
we're worshiping the Gargoyles like all
the idiosyncrasy all the strangeness and
but it's important to understand that
the carnival has a role or the carnival
isn't bad the carnival is good we need
the carnival Purim is a is like a
celebration in the Bible like it and we
have we have Mardi Gras we have Carnival
in the Orthodox tradition right so
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with Carnival it's always about its
place right and there's nothing and the
Gargoyles are fine if they're in the
proper place now if we flip it and then
we take the Gargoyles and put them on
the altar
right then you have the they have the
problem with the Abomination right you
have this and all of a sudden it becomes
like a scandal to have that uh and so
our our culture through many many
iterations has come to a point where
there is this like worship of
of Carnival is the only way to say it in
terms of entertainment in terms of of
the this kind of upside down and you
know swirling culture uh all of that is
is what what Carnival is think about
just like a giant Carnival wheel just
you're going around with like with uh
with clown music playing like that's
that that's what we celebrate so uh I
don't think politically it is possible
to deal with that because politically
the solution to that is not a great one
because politically it's like all right
well now we're gonna just bring the
knife down and you know the end of
Carnival is Lent right remember that and
so it's like we're gonna fast now and so
that's a dangerous it's a day it's like
a dangerous move when I showed you
ilinsky and the Russian constructivist
and the and the Russian artist the same
thing was happening in Germany things
were chaotic dada and all this weird
stuff and then the knife came down and
what you have after that is a kind of
authoritarian reaction to the carnival
and honestly I don't think politically
it's a solution that's why I think the
solution is a is a religious one there
is no other solution the solution is to
turn our hearts towards God
to become Saints to become to become the
thing that we're talking about to live
it out in our families to live it out in
the world around us and to know that
that you know that Remnant whatever
however it looks you know it will ride
the ark through the through the waters
uh and to me that is really uh you know
and I and I'm not against political
action I think political action is fine
but I but I don't think that I really
don't think the solution ultimately is
there
[Applause]
thank you Jonathan
um I wanted to just you know continue
with this conversation if you could
perhaps say a little bit more
um
about
following on RJ's question about the
Civic so the so the solution is not a
political solution it's at turning us
back to God but then could you talk us
through what that just what that would
look like right if we turned back to God
and then that specifically yeah well
because I think the implication was that
if we turn back to God it'll have an
influence on the Civic okay so I'm fine
I'm trying to talk about that one of the
problems we're facing right now
especially all you in America I'm
Canadian it's it's weirder but it's
different uh that is that one of the
problems we have is that if we don't
have the top place which is held by the
Divine logos
all we have are idols and so
one of the things that's happening is
that we expect the we expect the
founders of your nation we expect the
important people that have led to his
important historical uh transformations
to be God that's what we expect because
because the problem that's happening is
people are seeing their sin and then
they're freaking out like they're
Sinners destroy the statue
right and that's that's the problem
that's what happens like when Things
fall into the political sphere that's
what happens right those statues of
Stalin and of Lenin they are gods for
all intents and purposes they are the
highest point of attention
and so this is the this is the problem
now if if I think the medievals had a
really interest had an interesting way
of seeing it you know they they had this
whole tradition they called the nine
worthies where they would celebrate the
people the Ancients of the past and
there were there were a certain amount
that were uh like from the Old Testament
and then there was pagans and there was
people in their own age and you know
when they celebrated Alexander they
would say this is why we celebrate
Alexander and these are his sins
this is why we celebrate this person and
these are his sins but it's like yeah
that's it that's that's what it means to
be human but that is also because our
highest point of attention was beyond
those people right it wasn't a kind of
worship of the political leader it was
something which moved Beyond it so I
could I ask you maybe a follow-up to
that Jonathan you know we had a
conversation on YouTube a while ago
about Mary the Mother of God
and I've been teaching a class on
ecumenical Devotion to Mary here at
Princeton Theological Seminary and I
taught that class because there seemed
to be a renewed interest among my
Protestant students to think about Mary
Mary in Revelation Mary in scripture and
then I had a local artist who's here
with us today Juana Belcher whose art is
in the room come give a presentation on
prototypes of Marion art and boy the
students were just fascinated by the
images and so as I've taught this class
I've actually begun to wonder if maybe
you know we said you just said a moment
ago the answer isn't purely political I
I wonder if part of the enduring
attraction of Mary the Mother of God is
that it connects the liturgical and the
charismatic the church and the home and
that maybe what liturgical art can do
and proper veneration including
veneration for Mary the Mother of God it
can make the faith that you're talking
about personal and from the home then
can outflow the the the the grace to
build Unity right I mean I think
sometimes people want to build community
with a strategy anyone ever been to a
community building strategy session yeah
I mean you all laugh right Community has
got to be built person by person and I
think somehow I'm just conjecturing here
that Mary the Mother of God represents
that that personal person to person that
what happens in Sunday worship has got
to be taken into the home in into the
place of the messiness of home life with
pain and suffering but also celebration
and joy and from the church to the home
and then back out into society so is
that my question I guess is Mary the
Mother of God and
um
I know I think I think for sure the
mother of God is important in especially
even because she is in some ways that
body right she she's that place where it
comes together in the sense that she's
that Gathering you know you saw in the
image of Ascension it's well it's
beautifully represented where she stands
in the center and and all the all the
disciples gather around her you know
it's like she's this mother that is kind
of gathering them inside and so she she
is of course an image of the church like
the culmination of the of the church on
Earth you could say I don't know how to
say it in the right way uh but and then
then also she she's also been very much
the great protector of cities by the way
because she is also an image of the city
or the common or the the the coming
together people and so you know when
when the the
The Barbarians would come to the gates
of Constantinople they would take the
the icon of the mother of God and they
would parade on the walls with that icon
and there are many examples of you know
them just turning back or all kinds of
miraculous stories uh and then of course
the
the image of the protection of the veil
which some of you might have seen where
there there's a kind of a version of
that in Catholic art too you see the
mother of God standing above the church
and she's holding a veil which protects
you know the the common protects the
unity in the the Catholic tradition you
have this image of her with her with her
coat like her vestment open and then all
the people that are gathered inside her
and so I think that it's that definitely
there is something in order to embody
and in order to to be able to understand
the common and the places where we we
can recognize each other and recognize
each other as participating in something
that binds us that that her example and
her her guidance is useful
well and I'll just say I mean I I began
this morning you know and I talked to
you about how when I visited my mother's
home Village in Cuba that the villagers
came out and after 40 years they had
preserved the memory of the people that
had lived there before and the stained
glass windows with the Blessed Mother
and Roses not only had the church been
desecrated
the Rose Garden that my mother
remembered was gone right if we don't
protect our churches and our sacred art
people stopped planting roses
you know and then after time you know
what else happened they stopped working
because if we tell people that they're
only made to work and they're not made
to garden and they're not made to
worship people in Cuba stopped working
and I asked myself these people have
preserved for 40 years these windows
what have I preserved for 40 years you
know the only thing I could think of
that I've not thrown away in all my
moves well two things
photographs of family members I have
preserved
and an icon of the mother of God
that I got when my best friend got
married in Cyprus
and I've taken that icon and I've kissed
it I've slept with it when I was scared
or upset and it comes with me on every
single trip
photographs of my family and an icon of
the mother of God help me connect
remember past present and future help
keep me grounded to those Mysteries that
happen in the sacred liturgy and remind
me as you know Aiden talks as if it's so
easy to live up to our vocation as human
beings I often want to you know pull
back and just kind of put the covers
over my head
but when I have that icon with me and I
have the memory of the people who've
gone before me I remember that my life
has a purpose and that I'm participating
in something and I'm not doing it alone
thank you Jonathan
[Applause]